Good morning, Hank, it's Wednesday. So I just
watched a video by Nerdfighter suchducks in
which she claims that we don't make as many
inside jokes as we used to.
I don't know what to do about that, Hank,
except maybe to reveal, for the second time
in human history, the pizzajohn mustache.
That's right, Hank, the pizzajohn mustache
is like herpes and the Transformers franchise,
you can never be quite sure that it's gone
away for good.
But, Hank I suspect that even this is not
enough to satisfy suchducks so I shall wear
my pizza mustache while eating pizza and playing
the singamajig.
And then I'll go for a walk with my puppy-sized
elephant and the dread pirate Fireball Wilson
Roberts and French the Llama while wearing
a book called Tender Morsels in your pants
on my head.
"You didn't do the hand thing." "What?" :The
hand thing, you didn't do the hand thing.
I've been doing it the entire time with my
right hand, go back and watch. So, Hank it
should- Sorry, I'm having a really hard time
taking myself seriously right now, uhh, I
feel like I look like both a cop and a creeper,
Hank, so, like, I feel like I should be arresting
myself for creeping in the first degree.
Right. But anyway Hank, as I'm sure you're
aware there's been a lot of conversation on
Tumblr and the Ning and YouTube and Twitter
about Nerdfighteria changing as it grows and
how to keep the community strong as it grows
and etc and I just thought I would throw in
my two cents.
But first I want to establish two rules. Not
just for Nerdfighteria but also for, like,
general human existence. Uhh, number one:
don't be mean and number two: DFTBA. Hank,
I know those rules are hard to follow but
they are the rules! And if you break them
the half of my moustache that is a cop will
arrest you and the half of my moustache that
is a creeper will get creepy.
I can't look at myself in the viewfinder,
Hank. I can't take myself seriously. I have
got to get rid of this mouth caterpillar.
Ahh, so much better. Alright, Hank, first
I want to remind everybody that Nerdfighteria
has accomplished a ton in the last few months.
We've raised more than $10,000 with Esther
for This Star Won't Go Out. The Project for
Awesome generated more than 600,000 comments
and raised more than $150,000. We've broken
the email inbox of Warner Chilcott CEO, determined
that moon pasta is more efficient than earth
beef, transcribed every single vlogbrothers
video at nerdfighteria.info, and nerdfighters
continue to do amazing things all over the
world from dressing up as Phineas Gage for
Halloween to drawing regular squids of rational
debate and source citation to attending anything
but clothes parties while my face stares at
you creepily from the closet.
That said Hank, Nerdfighteria definitely needs
better ways to interact. Like, YouTube comments
are awesome but they don't really lend themselves
to building relationships or making stuff
collaboratively. The Ning is also awesome,
but can be very confusing, particularly to
new users; and Hank, Ning Masters are working
on that, but in the meantime some Nerdfighers
are building Your Pants. Hank, I'm sure you
remember that the original Brotherhood 2.0
forum was called "My Pants", well this is
going to be like "My Pants" except "Yours".
So hopefully in the next week or so "Your
Pants" will be live. It's going to be a great
place to build friendships and decrease world
suck and make Nerdfightastic things.
So keep watching, it'll be at yourpants.org
not yourpants.com. If you go to yourpants.com
Google will tell you that they can't find
your pants. Which, I mean, I don't expect
you to be able to find my pants Google, that's
my job. Google, your job is when I input a
symptom, you tell me what terrible disease
I probably have.
Alright Hank, here's the last thing I want
to say about Nerdfighting and civility. No
one can tell you if you're a Nerdfighter and
you can't tell anyone else if they're a Nerdfighter.
Nerdfighter is an identity that you choose
and then we collectively define that identity.
Not by talking about what it means, but by
living it. And in my opinion that goes for
almost all identities, from the ones we choose
like musician or writer, to the ones that
seem unchosen like brother.
Identities are important, but both the ones
you choose and the ones that choose you generally
resist simple definitions. I mean Hank, if
I've learned anything about brotherhood in
the last 4 years, it's that brotherhood is
about a hell of a lot more than sharing the
same parental units.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday. And Nerdfighters,
starting next week, I'll see you in Your Pants.
Sorry, I had to bring the mustache back for
that one. Movie magic!